malgré la pandémie plus de dix mille
personnes se sont réunies hier au
bangladesh pour une grande prière
collective
un rassemblement qu'on n'aimerait pas
forcément voir en ce moment pour être
honnête alors que le pays connaît son
premier décès est pose du coronavirus
officiellement 14 personnes sont
infectées mais les autorités suspectent
plus de cas en raison du faible nombre
de tests disponibles les écoles et les
universités sont fermées les
scientifiques redoutent particulièrement
la progression du virus dans ce pays de
160 millions d'habitants et pour cause
des millions de dix mille ressortissants
font régulièrement des allers et retours
à l'étranger